We just said that if we want to make a general statement about what the output,
based on a general input for this function we're talking about here, would be,
if the input was x, then the output would have to be x plus 2. Since the
function of our function is to increase all input values by 2. So, to illustrate
this point a little bit differently, we're going to so some very, very basic
computer programming. Now, don't worry if you've never done anything like this
before. This is just to illustrate how simple function works. You'll never be
tested on this or anything. This is just for you to explore and have fun and
maybe even understand things a little better. Now what we're going to do is to
use one particular programming language called Python, to create the same
increase by 2 function that we just did. Now remember, that we said in a general
case of wanting to increase by 2, we take an input of x and then have our output
be x plus 2. It's the same thing as happening up here in these two lines of
code. The letters def stand for define and they're saying that we're going to
define or create a function, which is named IncreaseByTwo, and that function is
going to take in some input, this letter x in this case as the general case. And
that function is going to do some stuff and then spit out this output, x plus 2.
So, these two lines of code are basically creating the machine that this
function is. The machine that transforms whatever input value it gets into some
output value. Now, please notice here that we do have parentheses here around
the input value. This is absolutely nothing to do with multiplication. These
parenthesis just indicate, this is what we are calling the input. let's try it
out. let's see if this function works. let's say that I want to use an input of 7
or plug in 7 in place of x in my IncreaseByTwo function. What number, do you
think, this program is going to spit out in the end. Now again, you don't need
to know anything about how programs actually work. All you need to do is think
about the relationship between the input here and the output here. And see,
then, what the output would be if 7 is the input. Please put your answer in this
box over here.